hi everyone you've probably noticed from
the lack of number file videos lately
and my grizzly adam's beard that i've
been away i've been in nepal doing
various bits and pieces but i've also
been keeping my eye open for bits of
numbery trivia and a few things i've
come back with that i thought were worth
sharing now anyone who knows anything
about nepal knows almost everywhere you
go you're being watched by these
buddhist wisdom eyes but one thing i
didn't know was that little curly nose
that looks like a question mark well
actually that's a number it's an ornate
version of the nepali number one its
symbolism is unity and here's the number
one
on their money you can see that's what a
one looks like and here's the number one
on a motorcycle license plate so there
are always numbers where you least
expect it another number that's really
important in both buddhism and hinduism
i learned was 108
and 108 is everywhere in nepal even
these recesses here cut in the stupa
there's 108 of them it's actually quite
good fun when you're in the poll seeing
how many places you can find that number
108 now here's another number 261.
that's the number of photos on this sd
card this card was found by my nepalese
track leader buddy while he was actually
going to the toilet in some bushes it
was raining and this thing was soaking
wet when he found it but we found out
later on the photos were still on there
i don't know whose photos they are but i
know if someone found my holiday photos
i'd want them to return them
so if you recognize these people
have a look at the link under my video
and help me get in touch with them
because i'd love to return their holiday
photos to them now that track was to
everest base camp and those of you who
are familiar with number five will know
that i actually went there last year
it's a place i'm really into
have a look at this photo i took this
year though there's mount everest in the
background 8
848 meters high we're having a bit of
fun there with a torch
i've already done a video about the
height of mount everest and some of the
numbers so have a look at that if it's
something that interests you and another
video we've done before is all about the
nepalese flag so that's one you can also
have a look at if you're interested
but this year what i did was as we went
to all the different elevations we
boiled water and had a look at how the
boiling point of water changes
and the boiled water temperature reads
88. i'm doing that video for my
chemistry channel which is called
periodic videos
so subscribe to that and have a look if
it's something you might be interested
in it's very numbery of course
and just to show that i'm always
thinking of number five i couldn't
resist getting a bit of footage of this
mountain here it's called
mount number that's number number i read
on the internet that some people say it
has the shape of a female breast it's
not something i can see myself but there
you go mount number for all the number
files
e
making b e equal to a b
four
touching e draw a line fg
starting from the point f on line ac
parallel to a b to the right